viens bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue sur
diagonale l'actualité internationale du
jeu d'échecs cette semaine et loi
actualité très fortes notamment le match
macromedia ski mais pas uniquement aux i
pas uniquement puisque nous avons
également été au sénat l'inauguration
des tables des chèques ou là nous avons
eu l'occasion de voir des personnalités
people qui s'intéressent au jeu d'échecs
notamment christian poncelet jean pierre
chevènement etienne bacrot should not
ils étaient tous là je le pied jean
becker réalisateur ainsi que josé
giovanni
on a rencontré la championne de france
que sin flir aussi le président de la
fédération française de préfiguration
anatolie weiser comme des meilleurs
joueurs français aussi
zohra ben azzouz my parade julie oui qui
était aussi au match détiennent contre
bédié ch'ti ou nous avons d'ailleurs une
très bonne interview de lui on vous
passera tout à l'heure donc match bacrot
millas qui est loi qui va avec
donc la victoire de védas qui justement
donc dû ainsi candidat au titre mondial
c'est peut-être un match un peu
difficile pour etienne mais bon il a
quand même réussi à égaliser un peu le
jeu peut-être un peu
il s'est lancé un peu trop à la taxe sur
la sur la deuxième partie oui disons
disons pour être pour rester simple que
etienne bacrot on n'a pas fait un
mauvais résultat
il a perdu deux matchs trois et demi
deux ans et demi et je veux quand même
contre alexander beddiaf clic est un
très très fort joueur
il venait juste de sortir du championnat
de france ça ils l'ont expliqué très
bien dans les interviews
donc il n'avait pas une mission facile
dans ce match contre alexander dyovskih
et le score je trouve qu'il s'en est
sorti de façon honorable disons il a
perdu une seule partie sur une
préparation aux deux bdf qui est il a
quand même tenu cinq nuls c'est à dire
que il a montré une fois de plus qu'il
est très solide et qu'il arrive à tenir
un joueur du top niveau mondial assez
facilement alors je crois qu'on a un
petit commentaire en faites sur la seule
formule du match par le père détiennent
macro oui pourquoi etienne decroux
fait-il des matchs et non pas des
tournois alors on va voir peut-être si
on peut passer
est ce que notre première voilà on va
passer tout de suite une interview je
donnais question maintenant tant
qu'organisateur ont peut-être la
dernière question qu'est ce que tu
penses de ceux de toutes ces nouvelles
formules puisque donc on secteur gagne
ce match ici des nouvelle formule de
championnat comme le choca du monde avec
partie en semi rapide des matches très
rapide à élimination directe
le championnat de france nouvelle
formule ou alors les anciens européenne
qu'elle est quel est le sens l'étendra
que tu préfères à ton avis quels sont
les avantages et les inconvénients de
chacun
bon personnellement j'ai un petit avis à
donner là dessus mais je crois que là
par exemple la formule des matches ici
donc ils sont qui permettent à etienne
en fait de se poser en match et est très
très très instructive
c'est quelque chose de très formateur
c'est le grand maître dorfman d'ailleurs
qui avait proposé cette idée il ya
quelques années et je crois que c'était
de bon conseil c'est bien entendu
différent d'un tournoi alors maintenant
pour revenir aux nouvelles formules
actuelles qui introduisent un petit peu
de la chance bon je pense que ça
certains intérêts mais je crois qu'un
long terme
on reviendra aux vrais formule qui ont
qui ont permis aux échecs de son essor
en fait c'est à dire les les longs
tournois les matchs les matches longs
etc
à partir du moment où on donne la valeur
d'une d'un blitz au départage à une
partie longue
bon je veux dire c'est sait plus
vraiment d échec c'est autre chose
décor moment-là on ira un peu à
l'encontre de la médiatisation du jeu
d'échecs dans la mesure où maintenant
avec les l'influent enfin toutes les 1
nouvelles informations les nouvelles
technologies tout se passe beaucoup plus
vite
donc les tournois rapide éliminations
spectaculaires sont quand même plus
recommandables je sais pas si je pense
que la médiatiser les les matchs qui ont
été vraiment médiatisé dans le monde des
échecs mais on pense aux grands matches
spassky fischer karpov kasparov et
cetera ça a été des vrais événements
médiatiques bon las vegas
malheureusement
on en a parlé que dans le microcosme des
échecs et le championnat de france a été
assez médiatisé cette année pas grâce à
la nouvelle formule grâce à la
participation de presque tous les
meilleurs joueurs français puisqu'il y
avait seulement le port médoc mannequine
qui ne jouait pas mais joël lautier
jouer et bien sûr c'était important et
en plus y avait une bonne organisation
d'ensemble avec la venue de karpov et
kasparov bon sens donc ça joue
énormément mais c'était clairement beau
tendre et ici l'organisation se passe
bien oui moi je suis qu'un pion dans
l'organisation mais on a la chance ici
d'avoir le support du du maire d'albert
qui est un amateur d'échecs qui était un
joueur classé et donc qui supporte les
échecs c'est une très bonne chose en
plus longs bains etienne joue dans sa
région
donc c'est c'est bien aussi pas d'accord
bon bah bravo et puis bonne chance et
bonne chance à etienne et merci d'avoir
répondu à cette interview donc eloi donc
l'avis de du père des siennes macro dons
qui lui est favorable vous échec
ancienne formule entre guillemets aux
échecs ancienne formule c'est vrai que
il a des arguments les matches car
peuvent kasparov espace qui fischer ont
été grandement médiatisée
je pense pas qu'on peut retrouver une
médiatisation tél avec le système
d'aujourd'hui mais disons c'est un autre
style avant c'était l'ouest contre l'est
ou alors kasparov l'apparatchik contre
karpov bien intégré dans le système
maintenant on va plus vers la médiatique
mondialisation et plus vers les grands
tournois plus spectaculaire alors je
sais pas les deux formules dans leur
avantage maintenant pour la justesse du
résultat c'est vrai qu'un match en six
parties donnent donc plus juste titre
encore en 20 parties va dire qui est le
meilleur des deux joueurs
alors que le championnat du monde
formule actuelle ne dira pas forcément
qui est le meilleur en font peut-être
trouver un mélange entre ces différentes
formules qui soient adéquates peut-être
trouvé comme nicolas d'ailleurs proposé
aussi un espèce de mixed aussi de tout
le tournoi fermé suivi de match peut
être un peu plus long après dans les
âmes damnées qualification oui c'est
vrai qu'on a on a bien parlé de toutes
ces formules en général moi
personnellement je suis pour les
formules rapides à élimination directe
comme le grand prix de bordeaux dé ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est etienne
bacrot organisateurs stéphane da krew
donc le père détiennent et aux
organisateurs
oui alors ça c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne chose pour etienne bien entendu
puisqu'il a maintenant une très bonne
expérience en match on a un peu coupé
l'interview de stéphane mais il a
rappelé qu'en mai l'historique de ces
matchs ils ont commencé par les vannes à
rognan donc tu étais un des meilleurs
juniors avec etienne ils ont aussi
organisé un match avec smith l'oeuf avec
porsche marie avec une ère qui sont tous
d'excellents joueurs de match donc et y
en a maintenant une expérience
considérable dans tout ce qui est
un contre un pour ainsi dire donc là un
contre un cette fois un peu à son
désavantage mais limite un peu plus tard
où il y aura peut-être une revanche il
n'a en l'air une possibilité de revanche
je croyais peut-être en guise en
slovénie d'ailleurs on est enfin bon
tout ça ne nous regarde pas en tout cas
à albert donc une maintenant une
tradition de match chaque année pour
etienne bacrot pourquoi parce que c'est
en fait c'était son club d'origine
maintenant je crois qu'on a l'interview
d'un responsable de l'administration de
la ville d'albert oui nous avons
rencontré l'adjoint au maire donc
jean-françois hu qui est l'adjoint au
maire d'auch pour le tout ce qui est
sport dans la ville d'albert voilà donc
si on peut envoyer une interview de jean
féger de la salle du jeu de paume avec
monsieur jean-françois eu donc qui est
adjoint au maire dans l'âge le cadre de
la jeunesse
la ville d'albert bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir alors première question comment
et pour quoi faire
organisez-vous cet événement autour d'
etienne est donc bien entendu quels sont
les moyens de mise en oeuvre par la
mairie et comment souhaitez-vous
continuer et bien en fait etienne est un
enfant du pays et on est très honorée
que etienne se souviennent qu'il ya
quelques années il a débuté à albert et
nous avons souhaité avec son accord
pérenniser en fait main chaque année un
match de dimension internationale qui
ont des retombées évidente pour la ville
d'albert économique en particulier par
exemple au niveau de l'hébergement de la
restauration ou même au niveau de
l'image d'une commune non que c'est vrai
qu' on est très honoré et à l'avenir on
souhaite toujours pérenniser avec
etienne bacrot qui est un joueur
d'échecs très prometteur et dont on est
fier qu'il ait pu commencer dans notre
commune sommes donc à terme vous
souhaite organiser le championnat du
monde entre etienne et son challenger au
mois de mars 2000 nous accueillons le
championnat du monde de billard
alors effectivement nous sommes rodés
aux championnats du championnat du monde
alors effectivement ce d'échec serait un
plus et avec etienne qui effectivement
est quelqu'un que nous soutenons nos
sentiments bien évidemment on en sera
très heureux et bien merci de soutenir
le jeu d'échecs et je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée
merci encore merci d'être venus en citer
d'encre en voilà et loi la cité d'encre
donc albert qui soutient etienne bacrot
donc on me disait ça fait donc des
années
mais quatre ou cinq ans que ces matchs
sont organisés peuvent en tout cas qui
est le vrai aficion comme on dit en
espagne pour etienne bacrot dans sa cité
oui qui est l'enfant du pays comme l'a
dit jean françois eu bon c'est vrai que
moi je trouve ça chauffe ça très bien
etienne développe beaucoup de jeu
d'échec c'est un bon ambassadeur du jeu
à mon avis il fait beaucoup de choses il
refuse jamais une interview il est trés
il est bien dans le pré rapport avec la
presse ce qui est je dirais
indispensable un peu comme peter l'écho
c'est la nouvelle génération qui est
bien bien mieux dans son temps que l'été
les anciens russes par exemple qui donne
déjà qu'ils ne parlaient pas anglais
donc il y avait le barrage de la langue
dans plus qu'ils refusaient
systématiquement les interviews
maintenant on va vers vraiment ce qu'on
a toujours rêvé c'est à dire savoir ce
que pensent les joueurs savoir ce qu'ils
font enfin connaître un peu leurs
secrets les ce qu'il ya dessous dans les
coulisses du jeu d'échecs en tout cas un
peu plus parce que connaît tous les
secrets s'est passé pas si facile que ça
on va passer maintenant
donc à la fin d'un match à la fin du
match en fait les lois qu'est ce qui se
passe en général afin dé match d'échecs
justement entre les deux joueurs d'une
partie alors quand le match est fini on
connaît le résultat on sait qui a gagné
qui a perdu et donc on assiste à la ce
qu'on appelle la remise des prix ou
alors on donne aux joueurs une médaille
un trophée ou une coupe plus c'est bien
entendu une enveloppe l enveloppe
contenant les prix les prix voilà donc
tout simplement est ici donc nous avons
filmé la remise des prix de ce match
entre je crois d'abord avant et loi
avant la remise des prix une fois que la
partie est finie
je crois que les joueurs analysent leur
parti et oui j'avais oublié donc il ya
une analyse de partir donc à la fin
d'une partie des deux joueurs en fait
voix en sarre les possibilités qu'ils
ont n'ont pas pu encore sain qui n'ont
pas pu donc jouer dans la partie
puisqu'on peut pas vraiment joué toutes
les parties possible et donc ils
confrontent leurs points de vue pour
voir jusqu'à quel point la profondeur de
jugement était bonne oui en fait l'idée
de l'analyse est simple c'est pas pas
forcément déterminé tient raison mais
plutôt de confronter les arguments de
chacun
connaître la vérité aux échecs c'est une
chose c'est difficile à laquelle peugeot
ce risque en tout cas enfin nous parce
qu'essayer de chercher donc là
simplement on peut confronter deux
opinions et ensuite l'analyse se fait
peut-être poser alors on va voir comment
est une macro et alexandre belov qui
analysent leur parti voilà donc là on
voit on va les deux joueurs en fait donc
c'est bien l'analyse c'est à dire que
les deux joueurs ici confrontent leurs
idées dont ils sont là détendue où il
lie à une main qui vient de passer ces
ora base moteur gilli l'entraîneur
détiennent bacrot qui a proposé un coût
mais enfin ce plan là surtout été filmé
sur les têtes des joueurs l'analyse non
plat vous voyez le sourire dtn c'est
beaucoup plus détendu c'est beaucoup
plus détendue évidemment que pendant que
pendant la partie
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on a vu
aussi un ballet alors on n'a pas pu le
montrer la main de balle et demain s'il
en a vu midi un bel et non puisque avait
un écran géant de projection qu'on n'a
pas montré ici qu'on entrera dans la
prochaine émission si si je crois en la
vie au début d'un générique dans le
générique est donc en voyait très bien
les mains des joueurs alors c'était très
impressionnant à l'analyse quand il y
avait des propositions de coûts assez
rapide enfin ça c'est si vous n'avez
jamais vu une analyse entre deux fours
joueurs c'est vraiment un moment à ne
pas manquer où il ya les mains qui se
croisent ils parlent russe en général et
c'est assez impressionnant à voir alors
la pression monte loi parce qu'on a vu
donc le père détiennent on a vu
l'organisation par l'intérieur monsieur
qui présentait le match on vient de voir
était dans la fin de la partie on va
voir maintenant ce qu'on dit tout à
l'heure après la fin de la partie là où
c est la fin du match la remise des prix
et après on aura enfin la possibilité
d'entendre les protagonistes on entendra
les deux protagonistes tout à fait c'est
vrai c'est quand même le plus
intéressant de ce reportage
alors en attendant remise des prix donc
de ce grand match etienne bacrot contre
alexandre belov ski à albert qui a duré
donc toute la semaine dernière remise
des prix
les i
bonsoir alors nous sortons de la remise
des prix de 10 avec la remise de la
coupe donc alexandre vinet ce qui était
très content je prends est très très
content d'avoir gagné ce match et c'est
c'était pour lui pas si évident que ça
on le verra peut-être tout à l'heure
dans son dans son interview que vous
découvrirez qu'il est assez humble sur
l'échiquier
il est assez ces aides en tout cas il
les dit des choses très très
intéressante alors la pl donc la partie
suivante c'est enfin donc l'interview
détiennent bacrot ce qu'on peut noter
c'est que on a peu l'occasion d'un temps
de tienkoikro en fait je crois qu'on l'a
vu sur tf1 antenne 2 il ya quelques
années et dont il ya trois 3 ans à peu
près de 3 en deux ans je sais plus
exactement quand il avait gagné son
titre de grand maître
et c'était à l'époque le plus jeune
grand maître de l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs à 14 ans et trois mois et trois
mois je crois donc qu'on l'avait entendu
un petit peu à la télévision et là on va
enfin avoir l'occasion de l'entendre ce
qui est pas une mince affaire
oui en fait c'est un peu en
contradiction est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure mais etienne et le joueur
moderne mais il est surtout très
concentré sur son jeu immobile pas
l'objectif principal qui est bien jouer
aux échecs donc alors les interviews
d'accord mais ni avant la partie ni
pendant le match c'est à dire qu'il faut
le prendre au bon moment où là il se
prête très bien aux jo l'interview c'est
à dire au général après le match alors
qu'on lie au bon moment et moi je pense
que le yoga ou oui puisqu'on lui alors
on va voir
etienne bacrot diagonale sommer albert
toujours le dimanche après midi avec
etienne bacrot donc tu viens de faire
nul contre alexander dyovskih la
dernière partie du match et tu perds le
match 3 et demi deux ans et demi quelles
sont tes impressions sur ce match on bat
aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu d'occasions de
prendre l'aventage ont même si si jay
carney pendant une vingtaine de coups
une position avec mon toutes les pièces
sur l'échiquier tout ça mais bon
finalement j'ai rien pu obtenir et c'est
logiquement qu'aujourd'hui
fait mieux mais mon dans le match j'ai
loupé deux occasions de prendre
l'avantagé en fait dans la première
partie j'avais l'occasion de peut-être
de prendre l'aventage à un moment j'ai
pas réussi voilà et dans là j'ai perdu
la deuxième en gt gt mal préparée voilà
c'est bon j'ai j'aurais dû revenir au
score dans la 4e j'avais un pion
d'avancé puis vraiment une bonne
position mais voilà j'ai toujours pas
réussi et je suis pas concrétisées mais
mes chances et lui il a réussi à la
gagner
d'accord donc en fait pas pas gagné une
partie dans le monde ces cinq nuls et
une défaite
c'est un score assez je dirais ennuyeux
entre guillemets quand on a la pêche et
qu'on est jeune qu'on a envie de gagner
qu'est-ce qu'elles le sont tus va tirer
de ce match bon les parties est assez
intéressante quand même c'était pas
c'était pas un match ennuyeux
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé de revenir à
chaque fois j'ai pas j'ai pas bien
réussi à prendre l'avantagé avec les
blancs c'est pour ça que que le score
est comme ça d'accord et donc dernière
question sur le match qu'on passera ton
actualité
comment est ce que tu t'es préparer pour
le match est ce que c'était pas trop
rapprochée du championnat de france sur
lequel on va revenir bien entendu
bien sûr c'était s'était rapproché du
championnat de france je sais pas j'ai
pas eu le temps de me reposer peut-être
comme il fallait
moi je sinon j'ai travaillé quelques
jours avec zohra base my paraphilie
avant le match est bon c'était s'était
rapproché du championnat de france mais
normalement j'aurais pu j'aurais pu
essayer de faire un meilleur résultat
oui on peut toujours faire mieux mais
alors bon cette année quand même tout
tout a réussit à gagner les bermudes en
début d'année de bonne augure
tu n'as pas disparu dans le triangle des
bermudes ensuite tu as gagné le temps de
lausanne donc les meilleurs ingénieurs
du monde tu as gagné le champion de
france 99
est ce que tout ça ça fait pas
un peu trop bas mais en général on peut
dire que j'ai quand même fait une bonne
année malgré que j'ai perdu ce match
j'ai gagné trois tournois
j'avais jamais fait cela auparavant trop
tendre dans une année c'est beaucoup
mais bon j'espère que que je vais
continuer à manger j'ai un match en semi
rapides contres judit polgar à bastia
normalement et sinon pour cette fin
d'année jeu je sais pas bien je vais
essayer de monde à bord je vais me
reposer après je vais je vais essayer de
bien comprendre pourquoi j'ai perdu le
match et j'ai d'essayer de m'améliorer
encore d'accord donc là tu vas jouer en
équipe de france
enfin tu veux faire le stage
d'entraînement avec marc touati qui à
naujac sur mer
donc qu'est ce que tu penses de cette
sélection française dans laquelle tu es
le leader puisque des champions de
france 99
bon ben c'est s'est passé c'est une
bonne équipe bien sûr il ya joël
christian bauer jeune david marty à noé
et laurent frayssinet non dans l'équipe
l'équipe titulaire ça va c'est une
équipe jeune qui est assez forte bombe
yousif ziv dorfman aura eu sa place
quand même oui moi j'espère que le stage
va bien se passer et puis après on verra
pour le championnat d'europe par équipes
ça je sais pas d'accord en tout cas on
souhaite bonne chance pour chappert
d'europe merci d'avoir répondu à ces
questions alors peut-être un dernier
petit mot pour tes fans c'est un peu
piège donc etienne bacrot en tout cas
très décontractée pour l'interview
ce qu'on a appris c'est son actualité
prochaine il va donc jouer un match
bastia contre julie couillard
oui contre judit polgar qui est une
spécialiste du jeu semi rapide j'ai dit
paul gars ne joue d'ailleurs
pratiquement plus que des exhibitions
semi-rapide enfin j'ai dans ma tête j'ai
dit aux gars est très très forte en semi
rapides à labatut karpov on se
rappellera la jouer un autre match sans
que je sais plus contre-pied en tout cas
j'ai dit aux gars jouent très bien ça va
être vraiment un très beau moment des
chèques à bastia je sais pas si on aura
des images de là bas de toute façon on
ira filmer judit polgar au tournoi de
golf
on essaie en tout cas d'un milliard
est-ce qu'on peut noter on va quand même
faire un peu de publicité portant à
bastia c'est un très très grand tournoi
avec beaucoup de prix et loi qui
commence à devenir donc un rendez vous
habituel annuel on peut en parler mais
je crois qu'il ya près de quatre cent
mille francs prix oui c'est la troisième
édition les prix augmentent
régulièrement
bon pour parler chiffres c'est je crois
que c'était 300 mille trois cent
cinquante mille quatre cent mille cette
année donc ça c'est l'ensemble de
l'ensemble des prières enveloppe
languedoc total des prix donc le tournoi
dure trois jours et le premier le
gagnant du tournoi gagne 50 me feront
donc pour les joueurs d'échecs c'est des
prix au dessus de la moyenne on va pas
dire le contraire
donc ça attire clairement les meilleurs
joueurs du monde
l'année dernière c'est alexander charlin
qui a gagné déjà qu'on n'arrive pas à
toucher le top 10 encore voilà c'est pas
à pas les 10 premiers quand même mais
mais effectivement atteint les 100
premiers il ya beaucoup de monde donc le
tournoi est pérennisée maintenant
puisque ça fait ça va être la troisième
édition ce qui conseille bien moi et
puis évidemment je vous parle pas de
bastia et bastia quoi bastia c'est
vachement sympa donc encore gelé mais
j'ai joué les deux premières éditions en
tout cas ça m'a toujours ça m'a toujours
fait très plaisir des yeux et donc pour
la première fois un match exhibition en
fait c'est un match exhibition comme
affaires etienne match semi rapide d'un
jeune théâtre à bastia bacrot bogard pas
rater ça on essaiera d'y être on verra
en tout cas alors maintenant donc on a
vu etienne bacrot on va évidemment pas
raté l'interview d'alexandre belliard ce
qui il faut le rappeler quand même c'est
un ennemi encore du monde ainsi un
candidat au titre mondial
il a été barré de sa route vers le titre
en fait en 83 84 et par le grand
kasparov au sommet de son art ça reste
une grande figure des échecs des années
80 trois îles aété quadruples champions
du rss ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
rien quand on sait que l'urss était la
nation est toujours quand d'ailleurs la
russie nationale juan dans le monde qui
gagnent régulièrement la championne du
monde des nations les olympiades
d'échecs est tout à fait bon alexander
medef tient ses seins c'est un monument
du jeu on ne peut pas vraiment dire plus
donc réaction de ce joueur très modeste
et et en même temps très fort toi alors
nous sortons de la remise des prix de ce
match etienne bacrot contre alexander
beliatski dans la somme à albert je suis
avec le vainqueur du match
alexander beliatski sens mr beliatski
apply match against french luxury and
what are you in motion ce match google
you think i was not so good for victory
logique à un match compliqué était
promis
ok sauf ue inde what can you say to
young player etienne jean une partie que
la hat vice can you give to etienne to
improve qu'ils les vols
because we know that with her expérience
aux matchs on offre just can't get you
can't give a
art et les angels en battant yoyotech
stoneham en politique français ce nom en
tête au cube store beliatski en
combinazione gagnent fort aux vices et
voilà alexandre il a skié loi bi tché bi
tché doivent ericsson drobinsky forme
d'interview on avait donc une grande une
grande chance d'avoir alexandre mais là
ce qui est en interview c'est sûr que si
on est allé le chercher en russie on
aurait peut-être eu moins de chance de
le trouver tout à fait non mais en tout
cas il est il est vraiment adorable
comme personne puisque donc qu'est ce
qu'il a dit sur etienne il a dit qu'il
pouvait pas lui donner de conseils ce
qui est quand même assez
je ne sais pas trop comment dire mais
c'est vraiment respectueux quoi ça veut
dire oui qu'ils estiment qu etienne sur
la bonne voie et à tel point qu'il
estime qu'il a même des chances de
devenir champion du monde
oui il est dit ça aussi mais je pense
que ça reste bien dans la philosophie de
second champion qui est que le vrai
travail c'est celui que l'on réalise
tout seul donc pas de pas de conseils
extérieurs
simplement il dit à étienne voilà le
mieux c'est que tu découvres tout tout
seul moi je n'ai pas de conseil à donner
je pourrais t'en donner mais c'est bien
entendu mieux que tu le découvres par
toi même peut-être ça rentre mieux et ça
reste mieux c'est plus dans son état
d'esprit et en plus bien entendu c'est
une méthode qui a fait ses preuves
voilà donc actualité sinon d'alexandre
vegas qui en fait pas de tournoi surtout
du jeu en équipe
oui oui apparemment ils jouent prix trop
avec c'est l'ère deschamps on a
peut-être un peu marre de la tension
nerveuse terrible cas dans les dernières
ont des tournois dans le jeu par équipe
c'est beaucoup plus décontractée dans la
mesure où on joue une partie cia toute
l'équipe qui est derrière
c'est quand même un jeu qui est plus
plus adaptée disons au jeu sans tension
je vous décontracter alors beaucoup de
russes
ce match est loin puisque l'entraîneur
détiennent lui-même et fait partie de
enfin était dans l'ex urss ça il s'agit
d'un joueur très fort puisque c'est le
14e joueur mondial
oui il s'agit du géorgien zurab admet
parachever lit alors le nom un peu dur
intégré mais donc c'est un joueur très
très sympas souriants ils jouent aux
cartes il est trés il est très très cool
quoi moi j'aime beaucoup ce joueur en
plus il est très fort puisque 14e
mondial c'est quand même assez
exceptionnel d'aucune entraîné tiennent
depuis un bout de temps déjà
ça doit bien faire six mois au moins je
me rappelle qu'il était déjà en gains
avec lui on l'avait vu d'ailleurs sur la
vidéo du tournoi d'enghien oui
d'ailleurs oui tout à fait voilà que
dire de plus à part montrer des images
voilà zohrab a smile parages unis
bonsoir donc nous sommes cette fois ci
avec durable hazemag parachever lee
l'entraîneur détiennent bacrot actuelle
et qui la seconde et pour toute la durée
de ce match somistes felli good evening
news non c'est china etienne bacrot
official trailer week end c'est so you
walk alone with etienne de yoplait
police match what are you in prochain
avant de ryzolt 1 2 watts kane bim
provigent etienne ce plat est ok
force
avec photoshop période
gestour x 228 x to play le match entre
qui donne tout
benjie after the good the bad and sur
tout le reste
just a few days to be a star to work for
laughs
c'est un pas de deux de ses mystères a
battu games with break
souvent des positions game suspecte
ok 2
et une amende
destineer soldat good est yen wa taillan
objective et maxime world championnat
face au wat soutiennent tout c'est
d'être né
we love sam evans à evanston tournament
2 par exemple
prepare to be or not to be
first to be next gaspar noé ok sauf you
very much robinson de we hope est
furieux voilà l oit l'entraîneur
détiennent qui donnait son avis sur le
match
oui tout à fait alors on les remarque
intéressante où il a détaillé un peu
pourquoi etienne avait perdu le match
il a dit un principe très juste c'est
que 16 ans il peut pas tout gagner
il doit perdre de temps en temps il faut
que il tire le maximum de profit de ces
défaites
c'est à dire qu'ils comprennent en fait
tout simplement pourquoi il a perdu et
la phrase finale est assez assez
sympathique c'est je pense que bon c'est
très dur d'être chantre du monde il faut
travailler beaucoup
il faut beaucoup de chance mais il a le
talent pour y arriver il a le talent
pour devenir un nouveau kasparov ses 50
escales exactement l'objectif qu'il est
c'est d'un tout cas de d'atteindre avec
avec son élève en fait son nouvel élève
ils ont tout un programme d'entraînement
enfin il travaille ses a priori travail
ils sont plutôt efficaces et très bien
le sens je dirais donc c'est un
entraîneur de talent très flou bon alors
maintenant on va voir un en tout cas on
peut dire que on peut dire si l'élève
dépasse le maître le maître étant déjà
14e mondial il ya des chances d'être
dans les premiers et tout à fait non
mais c'est un bon entraîneur
c'est un bon élève donc une belle
combinaison une belle combinaison alors
notre latin dont trois au portage sera
le ver se termine mais en ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on a mis en ligne donc la
partie la quatrième partie où etienne
aurait pu revenir puisqu'il a gagné un
pion dans une partie très tendue
alors je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
regarder cette partie donc il ya deux
façons de la voir vous pouvez cliquer
sur le bouton jouer qui est à votre
droite donc sur l'écran qui vous amène
sur une applet java sur lequel vous avez
la partie donc la quatrième partie du
match bacrot milevskiy deuxième option
et loi c on peut télécharger en cliquant
sur le bouton pgn le fichier pgn qu'on
appelle porter ball game notations qui
permet de suivre la partie sur des
logiciels
oui alors ça ça dépend de votre plate
forme entre les spécifications
techniques stéphane décoder mis au coin
puisqu'à la base c'est pas ma formation
donc je pense qu'il a tout expliqué
assez clairement
voilà donc de façon pour vous de voir la
partie soit directement sans en
regardant sur la sur le sur le donc sur
internet explorer ou netscape donc
j'arrive plus à trouver le mot voire
l'applet java ou alors charger le
fichier pgn pour le regarder sur un
logiciel spécifique que vous trouverez
en cliquant sur différé voilà donc voilà
pour l'évolution technique on n'aura pas
le temps et loi devant la partie parce
que maintenant on va voir un deuxième
reportage la semaine a été riche avec un
bel événement au palais au jardin du
luxembourg
très bel événement donc à paris cette
fois on la sait plus vraiment du jeu
d'échecs
c'est l'inauguration des tables des
chèques mais qu'est-ce que ça permet de
découvrir le jardin du luxembourg déjà
très beau jardin appartenant au sénat
avec beaucoup de joueurs d'échecs c'est
à dire c'est un jeu qui est complètement
différent ce n'est pas un tournoi c'est
pas un match c'est pas un blitz c1 le
jeu les joueurs de jardin c'est pas du
jeu sur internet en plus c'est les ans
un joueur qui aime venir ici à cadre
agréable soleil ou même de forts joueurs
qui viennent aussi il ya même d'autres
fort joueur même temps fort qui vient et
ça fait donc des années que ce jardin
accueille des joueurs donc régulièrement
on peut aller donc jouer au jardin du
luxembourg
donc le sénat a eu l'initiative de
de mettre en place des tables
spécialement fait pour le jeu d'échecs
voyant la tradition qui s'était établi
et donc on va en retrouver un événement
grandeur nature on va peut-être pas un
détail et plus ces lois et on va y
arriver nous on était très très bien
mise en relief très très haut on a très
bien fait mousser l'événement et tout le
monde était là tout le monde était là
alors voilà première premier petit
passage vidéo sur le jardin du
luxembourg
l'essence est ce une guérison
ils ont produit un de rejoindre vous
savez le jardin du sang vous êtes abonné
une traditionnelle les joueurs d'échecs
comme dans beaucoup de pluie dans le bon
film réalise et houcine fois que l'on
découvre et nantes
mais curieusement rien n'a vraiment été
beaucoup vous jouer confortablement
déchets le transformer en table mais les
problèmes vont à présent se gêne pas je
pourrai rien pendant encore le sénat ne
s'est pas aperçu de l'honneur que vous
faites vous de l'avoir choisi pour
indiquer aux disciplines revient en
installant gétaz gens ont voulu d'abord
vous avez un mobilier confortable qui on
a vu on a vu des personnalités de
premier plan en france
alors nous avons vu le président du
sénat lui-même
christian poncelet nous avons vu
également le ministre jean pierre
chevènement de l'intérieur ministre de
l'intérieur ce qui n'est pas le plus
facile
on a vu aussi etienne bacrot effacer le
veilleur nos deux champions de france
actuellement 99 féminin et masculin donc
un joli plateau pour l'inauguration
lorsqu on a ce qu'on a vu aussi ses qui
avait beaucoup de monde autour et
beaucoup de télévision beaucoup de
journalistes et dans l'élan de public
d'ailleurs il y avait des gradins pour
empêcher que tout le monde puisse venir
l'arrière c'était une très bonne
manifestation beaucoup tous les joueurs
habituels du jardin était là il y avait
toute la presse donc latine et pris
l'habitude elle qui était la grosse
effervescence quand même dans les
jardins du sénat pour accueillir ces
personnalités
alors suite à ce discours d'inauguration
d'un christian poncelet convient donc de
voir eloi donc on va voir maintenant
qu'après des partis sont organisés entre
les personnalités
il y avait aussi des cinéastes des
réalisateurs on va voir tout de suite je
crois une partie très intéressante avec
enfin une ambiance de ces différentes
parties et après on commentera les
personnalités que qu'on a pu voir jouer
donc une petite démonstration après sept
discours de christian consommant que
l'inauguration d'étape des chèques pour
à proprement parler avec les premiers
joueurs qui les premiers utilisateurs de
ces nouvelles tables voila voila si on
peut passer
c'est un pur film en creux jean becker
on démarre
d'ailleurs
rapide ici donc on voit on a vu la femme
détiennent de joël lautier ici christine
flir championne de france hélas le great
entre jean-claude loubatière à droite
président de la fédération rencontre
bachar quoi tu lis ici
alors ici il ya donc jean becker à
droite contre jean pierre chevènement si
je me trompe pas à gauche et or la voilà
le clou le clou vraiment le le clou de
cette inauguration a smile parent
juillet à droite qui joue contre un
atelier weiser champion de france 97 un
téléphone a en même temps et il
téléphone en même temps alors pourquoi
on sait pas ça par les russes je pense
que alexander bedritsky était en train
de négocier l'arrivée se voit là
prochains temps donc voila voila ces
différentes personnalités
donc on a vu qu'on a vu six jouets
beaucoup de plaisir je crois et des
personnes qui sont venues comme on va le
voir peut-être un peu plus tard avant
tout pour médiatiser le jeu d'échecs
s'est on se rend compte que beaucoup de
gens en fait beaucoup beaucoup de gens
jouent aux échecs et y compris d'un
décès des personnes qui font tout autre
chose oui ça c'est vrai enfin il y avait
un dvd vraiment du beau monde dans ce
jardin
c'était avant tout une était très
conviviale c'était vraiment agréable
d'être là bas on sentait que tout le
monde était détendue c'était vraiment
une bonne ambiance avec des gens sympas
et des joueurs d'échecs venus de toute
la france de toute la france même de
toulouse même de tous feront aussi et de
bordeaux de bordeaux tout à fait donc
beaucoup de monde alors on a aussi des
gens qui viennent de montpellier
puisqu'on a vu tout à l'heure
le président de la fédération dont
jean-claude matière qui était présent
aussi donc pour cette inauguration donc
ça a attiré beaucoup de monde on voit
que quand les institutions s'occupe un
peu de du jeu d'échecs mais tout le
monde vient donc on va voir maintenant
une interview du président de la
fédération jean claude de l'aube à
thiers oui ce cher jean claude dont nous
sommes au sénat avec jean-claude
loubatière le président de la fédération
française d'échecs alors ici c'est un
événement très médiatique et très bon
pour les échecs à priori comment la
fédération le soutien et qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous concède cet événement
tout simplement
bon d'abord c'est un événement qui est
très important pour les échecs parce que
les échecs c'est tout c'est internet qui
arrive c'est jouer celle contenant un
ordinateur s'est jouée
traditionnellement et puis c'est aussi
joué dans les jardins publics avec les
légendes des gens qui aiment les échecs
qui se passionnent qui viennent voir et
donc aujourd'hui c'est une forme de
reconnaissance pour ce type de jeu qui
n'a pas disparu d'accord alors ici vous
avez donc vous avez été déjeuner au
sénat et donc on est apparemment tous
les gens sont contents vous avez des
biens reçus il ya beaucoup de joueurs
d'échecs
comment un événement comme ça peut-il
être organisé enfin quels sont les
secrets d'une réussite par ailleurs moi
je crois qu'il veut partout il faut qu
est ce qui m détonateur quelqu'un qui
sommes motivés bon dans le cabinet dudit
sénat il ya un joueur d'échecs et qui
est motivée qui a été certainement
celui qui a initié le projet est donc
après bon le projet se monte et puis
c'est bien d'accord l'actualité fédéral
pour la médiatisation la médiatisation
du jeu c'est ça passe par quoi ça passe
par beaucoup de choses
bon c'est un petit peu une question
difficile parce que bon c'est d'une part
les échecs spectacle s'est d'autre part
les échecs chez les jeunes c'est un
internet une des compétitions par
internet
donc il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
volets et puis c'est bien sûr nous nos
champions que soit etienne bacrot
champion de france marie ce bac
championne d'europe des moins de 14 ans
d'accord donc la fédération bien avec
son temps dans la technologie immersive
sur le batteur donc il doit même le même
le président la fédération était là à
les obtenir qu'il était est assez
content que cet événement oui il a fait
un blitz contre bachar quitely alors
bachar quoi qui peut être candidat à la
présidence de la fédération en tout cas
c'est un des candidats potentiels et ils
ont fait match nul dans cette belle
partie il paraît que jean claude avait
pris avantage et jean claude a raté un
moteur 2 alors bon mais ce n'est pas
habituel pour lui puisqu'il faut quand
même pas c'est bien aux échecs c'est un
passionné du jeu il à 2100 2002 ce qu'il
passe quand même un niveau international
c'est raisonnable et sharko t-bonds bien
entendu et de remettre des chèques est
toujours très très bien donc un match
qui était qui était intéressant
peut-être bachar et fumer un peu trop de
cigares cette façon est donc dans une
partie nulle
donc maintenant il reste il reste encore
du monde d'ailleurs on va pas tout
pouvoir tout passé loi puisque on va en
garder un peu pour la semaine prochaine
puisque en fait on pourra pas tout cas
les tellement il y avait de monde mais
il nous reste deux encore des
personnalités très intéressante à voir
notamment encore une fois quelqu'un
qu'on connaît bien puisqu'on l'a vu tout
à l'heure eh bien il s'agit de etienne
bacrot le jeune étienne champion de
france 99 qui a perdu le match en guyane
ce qui donc il était encore là au sénat
avant de partir pour ce fameux match ce
fameux entraînement avec marc doury tri
à naujac sur mer dont on a parlé pendant
une interview avec lui donc la star
française et d'échecs etienne bacrot
deuxième toujours au sénat pour cette
inauguration des tables d'échecs avec
cette fois la star la star de
l'événement était une macro bonjour
etienne salué la loi donc tu es partout
web à albert jardin du luxembourg est
sauvé oui je bouge beaucoup et alors ici
tu es venu tu as donc d'y manger au
sénat avec toutes les personnalités et
là tu viens de faire des parties contre
des joueurs people célèbre web un repas
c'était très sympa donc avec les gens
que je connaissais déjà un peu et puis
là j'ai fait j'ai fait une partie contre
jean becker j'étais pas positif contre
lui j'avais fait deux nuls en simultané
mais l'a finalement j'ai réussi à me
reprendre et c'est bon j'ai gagné la
partie d'acord obtus de sens à l'aise
dans ce genre de manifestation tu es un
bon ambassadeur du jeu moi peut-être
etienne pas très convaincu bon bah merci
pour cette interview et bravo pour ce
que tu fais pour les échecs
ouais bah merci et ouais bravo à toi
pour ton pot la turne alice c'est très
bien ouais merci
alors je vous demande et moi et moi s'il
te chambrer pas c'est un petit peu ça
enfin en tout cas il est beaucoup plus
décontractée que
l'interview est prête sur 2,2 après le
match c'est normal puisque c'est très
fatigant une partie frappe les que les
parties comptent bidasses qui dure en
moyenne 4 heures en fait en 24 heures
c'est pas facile mais alors là il était
bien souriant et 10 chambres un peu mais
quand même à son âge
en tout cas très très sympathique donc
etienne était donc invité par le
président jean arnaud bon en fait ils se
sont rencontrés avant je crois qu'il ya
eu un repas informel
enfin oui il paraît que c'était
d'excellente qualité excellente qualité
on imagine dans la présidence du sénat
ça doit être agréable ils sont tous
ressortis avec des cigares énorme ont
donc en tout cas il a été bien reçus au
sénat par christian poncet dont
l'initiateur en fait on y reviendra
après qu'est-ce qu'on a une autre
interview montrer plus tard tout à fait
alors parler il termine encore
intéressantes
après le champion de france on va voir
l'interview maintenant du numéro un
français depuis des années
c'est le plus fort joueur français joël
lautier il s'agit de lautier sans
surprise bon il est très fort il a raté
son championnat 37 années les autres
tournois lyon bien réussi globalement 99
ça a été une année
un peu de retour de joël lautier après
une grande période difficile il s'est
fait éliminer au champion du monde de
las vegas en huitième de finale contre
boris qu'elle fonde ce qui était donc
pas si facile c'est sa bête noire un peu
donc là joël lautier un peu tranquille
en vacances dans ses jardins
d'inauguration tout cas voilà je vais
lautier pour la première fois sur des
gones a totalement enfin en visibilité
totale puisque on l'avait passé une fois
uniquement en analyse et on n'avait pas
vu pour un problème de montage
je vais lotis
bonjour alors on est au sénat donc la
première remarque et tu m'as fait on
arrive aussi c'est qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme joueur d'échec c'est
impressionnant qu est ce que tu peux
détailler un peu ce propos oui c'est
vrai je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y ait
autant de joueurs en plus des joueurs
que qui habite d'habitude ne sont pas à
paris et parce que l'impression qu'ils
se sont déplacés spécialement pour
l'événement donc c'est un peu surprenant
tu viens je jouais au luxembourg
d'habitude où tu ça fait longtemps que
tu viens plus je venais pas très souvent
pourtant j'habite pas très loin du
luxembourg mais bon c'était pas dans mes
habitudes mais je pense que je passerais
plus haut on faire un tour d'ailleurs ce
week end italien on peut faire des blitz
bon un petit match de blitz avec joël
alors donc un dernier petit mot vous
avez été reçu au sénat c'était bien ah
oui c'était très bien et c'était très
bon aussi on a bien mangé et en plus
c'est agréable de voir que les échecs
bâtir attention bon des gens qui peut
faire quelque chose pour que le jeu
d'échecs se développe eh bien merci joël
et puis bonne bonne fin de journée
bonjour toujours dans thor voilà donc
on a aperçu juste après christine
fleurent on le passera passera cette
interview la semaine prochaine j'aurai
lautier très décontracté ou alors ce qui
est bien et que joël c'est que même
quand les questions sont à bonn les
réponses le sont quand même là quand
même réussi à dire tout ce qui veut tout
ce que j'avais envie qu'ils disent en
fait tout ce que je peux et sans que je
lui demande
j'étais pas encore chaud c'était la
première interview de la journée donc
c'était pas la plus facile
ce qu'on peut noter donc là on a vu donc
le champion de france 99 donc etienne
bacrot on a vu jouer lautier mais
évidemment il y avait aussi d'autres
personnalités tout à l'heure on a vu
chez vainement donc le ministre
l'intérieur bon évidemment christian
poncelet puisque c'est lui qui est à
l'initiative de l'opération
donc on l'a vu aussi des personnalités
du show business du show business entre
guillemets enfin windows même total il
s'agit de des réalisateurs josé giovanni
et jean becker qui sont vraiment des
fans inconditionnels de jeu comme on va
le voir dans les interviews
oui d'ailleurs c'est pas la première
fois que jean becker rencontré etienne
mais on va peut-être laissé etienne le
soin de raconter pourquoi oui oui par
contre je sais que je le lotti avait
déjà rencontré josé giovanni
alors cette fois les rôles étaient
inversés puisque c'était josé giovanni
qui commentait son propre film joël
était dans le public et lui a posé des
questions
à propos de cinéma donc josé giovanni ne
savait pas qui était ce ce monsieur
c'est petit monsieur finalement c'était
lautier quand même donc voilà si on peut
passer maintenant on a une interview
donc des réalisateurs jean becker et
josé giovanni ou donc au jardin du
luxembourg
nous sommes donc au sénat avec nos
réalisateurs préférés
donc jean becker josé giovanni et le
jeune génie français etienne bacrot donc
d'abord une question pour la fin les
réalisateurs vous aimez beaucoup de
choses des chèques ça on le sait vous
êtes venus ici c'est très gentil
donc en fait vous êtes venus avant tout
pour jouer ou pour médiatiser le jeu
d'échecs pour médiatiser de jeu d'échecs
d'abord parce qu'on pense que c'est
nécessaire je crois que c'est au niveau
scolaire derrière moi je crois que ça va
devenir plus ou moins une non pas
obligatoire mais mon petit fils par
exemple on lui donne un choix il peut
apprendre à gérer l'échec à l'école
donc je pense que je crois que c'est une
grande ouverture d'esprit que c'est très
bien que ça apprend à vos enfants à se
calmer par moments il ya à prendre
j'ai pas une manière de classification
de l'esprit voilà jeu
je peux c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
faire de mon mieux pour essayer de que
les échecs soit plus connue en france
d'accord même chose je suis venu pour
médiatiser les échecs parce que je joue
plus depuis un moment mais enfin si
c'est une passion pour moi et ça reste
quand même dans la tête une passion ça
m'a beaucoup appris ça m'a ça m'a calmé
j'étais un attaquant prématuré même dans
la vie un très violent et je crois que
ça a été une bonne bonne thérapie pour
moi les échecs
d'accord c'est très intéressant donc les
échecs scolaires les échecs thérapie est
pour toi etienne les échecs passion jeu
ou métiers main pour moi c'est une
passion où j'essaie toujours de
m'améliorer pour faire de bons résultats
voilà je trouve très bien que que des
gens des gens connus nous aident pour
promouvoir le jeu d'échecs est alors pas
de pardon mais heureusement qu'il ya des
gens qui justement ces récents quand
même qu'il peut y avoir des gens comme
joël comme nuit que mais je dire qu'ils
chantent comme toi si c'est vrai c'est
vrai ccc avance qu'ils n'existaient pas
ou votre peut il ya eu quelques joueurs
français mais là en ce moment il ya une
recrudescence de jeunes joueurs français
qui montrent leur danse eh bien voyez
alors deux questions une dernière petite
question est-ce que vous avez des
enfants ace qui joue aux échecs 1 alors
j'ai des enfants qui jouent qui joue un
petit peu chez les petits enfants qui
jouent aussi très peu mais quand en
vigueur on a envie de jouer donc je sais
pas si je vais les pousser à jouer mais
en tout cas à chaque fois qu'ils me
demandent de vin j'aime bien jouer avec
lui car ça me fait plaisir aussi manger
ma fille qui m'a tant est grande
35 ans qui joue aux échecs jeu après je
sais qu'elle joue aux échecs mon fils
j'ai pas pu peut-être avec mes petits
enfants les deux plus petits la toute
petite fille de rien du tout je vais
peut-être essayer de leur un pointage
aux échecs il faut pas les forcer c'est
une passion comme disait josé c'est à
dire que on a envie
je crois que je tienne c'est pareil je
te pose la question est ce que toi tu as
pas forcer à jouer ça t'est venue de
josé shaked a bien envie de faire ça 1
voilà fort bien sûr sévigné tous à venir
il vient de lui-même c'est formidable
voilà je dois dire a ajouté que vous
savez les échecs aussi bien dans les
sanatoriums les maladies de longue durée
ont sauvé beaucoup de gens parce que ça
les a tirés de leur maladie ça les a
empêchés de penser à leur maladie aussi
chez les prisonniers qui en jouent aux
échecs s'évade de la prison ils ne sont
plus dans la prison
d'accord et ben merci beaucoup c'était
très instructif alors j'ai vu que vous
avez joué trois parties que trois ou
quatre parties qu'elles étaient le
résultat de lyon 6e 6e jeu c'était mon
nom c'est moi qui ai appris à jouer xavi
qui va leur donner le bon merci beaucoup
voilà des lois des passionnés parler
clairement des passionnés en plus des
réalisateurs de total ont donc que
demander de mieux pour le jeu d'échecs
je sais pas en tout cas mais peut-être
d'organiser un match
etienne bacrot jean becker peut-être au
palais des congrès à paris en tout cas
c'est un fort joueur puisqu'il a battu
aussi jean pierre chevènement il y avait
fait deux nuls contre tienne maquereau
ou un simultané
donc on me disait tout à l'heure en fait
il n'y avait pas encore réussi à gagner
une partie contre jean becker danse et
un simultané y jouer qu'entre juin mais
c'est donc un joueur d'un très bon
niveau
ah oui oui c'est clair mais j'ai regardé
un peu ces parties contre josé geovanni
justement et la partie se tenait
c'étaient les pièces qu'elle est plus ou
moins au bon endroit
moi je dis pas qu'il ya pas d
imperfections en tout cas les parties
étaient assez
on sentait qu'ils les bases étaient
bonnes et qu'il y avait un peu
d'originalité en plus
alors pour organiser donc un événement
comme ça et donc une opération parce
qu'il s'agit de placer des tables qui
sont maintenant présentes tous les jours
au jardin du luxembourg
il fallait des organisateurs des gens
qui a eu l'idée de le faire et donc il
s'agit de bertrand guyard guillard et de
yves marek qui est au sénat donc mais on
va voir tout de suite voilà une
interview des deux organisateurs des
deux initiateurs en fait du projet
bertrand huillard et donc yves marek
organisateurs
luxembourg dans les jardins du sénat aux
échecs et ça fait des années que
j'attrape des scolioses ça fait des
années que je me disais ça serait bien
qu'on est très beau jeu l'échec et j'ai
on en parlait on en parlais avec mon ami
yves marek et un jour il a été nommé
conseiller du président du sénat et ce
rêve est devenu réalité grâce à lui mais
je crois que c'est la meilleure chose à
faire c'est peut-être lui demandait de
savoir comment il a réussi à convaincre
monsieur poncelet le président du sénat
de mettre des échiquiers ici donc
monsieur yves marek vous êtes âpres a
apparemment passionné d'échecs également
vous êtes au sénat alors comment avez
vous fait pour convaincre le président
du sénat à la vérité je n'ai eu aucune
difficulté parce que il a trouvé tout de
suite l'idée a tout à fait naturel en
dépit du fait qu'ils ne jouent pas aux
échecs et donc ça va s'arrêter très vite
je lui proposais la chose mois de mai on
a étudié les tables en juin comme c'est
un matériau très difficile à fabriquer
il a bien fallu deux mois pour le faire
elle était sèche à peu près vers le 10
septembre et on les installe aujourd'hui
le 21 d'accord et bien en tout cas je
vous félicite tous les deux merci
d'avoir répondu à ces questions et
passion et moyens ça donne une très
belle manifestation remercie donc voilà
il voit on arrive pile poil à la fin
notre émission effectivement une très
belle organisation très bel événement
est maintenant bel endroit paris pour
jouer quand il fait beau oui alors les
tables sont très très jolie moi c'est la
première chose qui m'a frappé
donc c'est des tables on lave la
gouaille et l'âge de pierre
oui en tout cas c'est très joli à
entendre et c'est très joli à voir
également
il suffit d'amener ces pièces
puisqu'elles sont pas en libre service
sur l'échiquier et une pendule les
pièces une pendule et on a un très bon
endroit pour jouer avec des tables bien
stable qui pèse 45 kilos quand même donc
on est bien on est bien et on peut donc
aller au jardin du luxembourg dans
l'espace qui entre eux les terrains
tennis et le palais du sénat
l'espace réservé aux joueurs d'échecs
voilà donc un énorme bourde
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de
diagonale donc le match bac robin haase
qui victoire d'alexander belafkih avec
une victoire à zéro et donc au sénat
inauguration d'un nouvel espace
échiquier par christian poncelet et loi
je crois que tu vas probablement partir
en chine à pékin et donc nous nous
revoyons je crois qu'il n'est pas la
semaine prochaine ni la suivante digne
est la suivante donc dans trois semaines
tu reviens et la semaine prochaine je
crois que nous recevons nicolas giffard
ne manquez pas diagonal la semaine
prochaine actualité internationale des
échecs sur canal web
le
oui